well ndot is about to begin a pilot
program to improve hov lanes and help
tackle traffic nightmares now we're told
sensors being installed at more than 15
locations along the 15 and u.s 95 will
document how many passengers are in a
vehicle driving in the carpool lane
every day trenton wilson says two hours
of his day is getting through traffic
that's why he uses the hov lanes to help
minimize the stress they're useful
sometimes
starting sunday construction will begin
at 17 locations along the i-15 and us-95
where sensors will be installed as part
of a pilot program for the hov lanes
those sensors are going to be able to
measure the number of cars the speed of
those cars and
we'll be able to determine whether or
not those vehicles have two or more
passengers justin hopkins with the
nevada department of transportation says
the multi-year study will help with
hours of operations and other
modifications over the next 18 months
hov lanes are
can substantially reduce
emissions they encourage carpooling
which can reduce traffic
can get people to their destinations
quickly the 24-hour high occupancy
vehicle lanes are for two or more
occupants in the vehicle and no more
than two axles motorcycles rtc buses and
emergency vehicles are also allowed on
these lanes hopkins says each location
will require three to five days of
overnight lane restrictions for
insulation and testing which this
commuter says will only cause more
traffic nightmares it's terrible and i
think it's because of those all those
orange cones everywhere there's like an
orange cone every five seconds
all right those sensors will only be
able to document the number of vehicles
and its passengers but it will not
identify speed or the model of the car
ndot says that's handled by law
enforcement